komisch ich werde gerade ein bisschen
emotional entschuldigung ich wohne
aktuell wirklich wieder bei meinen
Eltern ich bin dort wieder eingezogen
weil ich hier nichts finde weil ich mir
nichts leisten kann mit 35 zieht PIL
diminger wieder in ihr altes Zimmer
später zeigt sie uns wie Wohnungsnot
aussehen kann nirgendwo sind die Mieten
so hoch wie hier in München aber wieso
eigentlich welche Rolle spielt die
Ampelkoalition dabei und wie könnten
Supermärkte
helfen München die Hauptstadt ist Luxus
und das hat Folgen 2200 € warm fin
einhalbzimmer München ist jetzt nichts
Neues ist keine Herausforderung die
findet man also für die Bewohner von
München die wenig Einkommen haben gibt's
keine finanzierbaren Wohnungen das ist
nch mal so viele von denen sind da
auchch so nah der Verzweiflung ist es
ist halt allgemein schlimm und ich
glaube jeder weiß wie die Lage ist in
den vergangenen Jahren klettert die
Kaltmiete für eine sanierte oder eine
Neubauwohnung auf durchschnittlich 22 €
pro
Quadratmeter eigentlich war die Stadt
einmal stolz auf die Münchner Mischung
also ein Mix der Gesellschaft unabhängig
vom Geldbeutel die Münchner Mischung
meint aber auch die Ökonomie es gibt
einen ganz starken Sektor von
Technologieunternehmen
Apple Google ist da Amazon ist da Meta
ist da und so weiter und die sind alle
da weil wir auch ganz tolle
Universitäten haben weil wir tolle
Forschungseinrichtungen haben und das
zieht wenn das funktioniert über die
Jahrzehnte so tut es zieht es natürlich
viele Menschen an die Preise treffen
alle in der Stadt aber nicht in
derselben Härte am schwierigsten ist es
für die Alleinerziehenden und für die
seniorinen und Senioren und dann haben
sie z.B eine ältere Dame die 700 € Rente
hat und in einer Wohnung wohnt die
gerade noch so mit allen Abstrichen für
Sie finanzierbar ist und bekom kommt
dann eine Erhöhung wir schauen uns das
ehemalige Arbeiterviertel Giesing an die
Gegend skalt vor ein paar Jahren als
vergleichsweise günstig inzwischen
spitzt sich auch hier die mietlage zu
überall ragt grauer Beton aus dem Boden
mehr Wohnraum für mehr Menschen aber wer
kann das eigentlich
bezahlen wir fragen ein paar Leute vor
Ort und landen bei
Pilar hi
binul ich komme von hier ich war D Jahre
in Hamburg und bin wieder hierher zurü
warum bist du wieder hergezogen
tatsächlich wegen der Familie also wegen
meinen Eltern das sind nur meine Mama
und mein Papa und ja und auch ich bin
hier verwurzelt ich muss es wirklich
sagen Pilar ist 35 Jahre alt und
arbeitet als Kommunikationsdesignerin
und itberaterin für
seniorinen gerade ging verändert sich ja
glaube ich viel also auch hier Ecke ja
sehr wie nimmst du das wahr wie wie
verändert sich
ging
ist komisch ich werde das gerade ein
bisschen emotional entschuldigung das
ist ich frage mich echt irgendwie gerade
wie du das geschafft hast
aber es wird halt sehr viel teurer ja
also es ist so ich wohne
hier direkt dort und ich bin dort auch
aufgewachsen und wenn du jetzt sagst es
ist schwer hier was zu finden also was
suchst du denn und mit was bist du so
konfrontiert bei dein also ich bin
einfach dit konfrontiert dass ich eine
selbständige Frau bin und nicht sehr
viel verdiene und natürlich dann
deswegen oft abgelehnt werde und ich
befürchte halt einfach auch dass das
sehr konventionelle Strukturen hat
sprich das Vermieter denken könnte ich
könnte heiraten und Kinder bekommen und
deswegen wieder schnell raus sein ich
habe keinen Mann der mich vielleicht
irgendwie absichern könnte
um die Miete länger selber zu bezahlen
und wahrscheinlich hat es auch damit was
zu tun dass ich noch nicht sehr lange
selbst B heute wird sie sich noch
überwinden und uns zeigen wie sie
momentan
lebt aber wieso bekommt das reiche
München das Problem nicht in den Griff
die Stadt investiert mehr als 2
Milliarden Euro in Projekte wie
Sozialwohnungen und wohnförderungen
schon eine kleine Familie mit einem
Jahresbrutto von 80 000 € kommt dafür in
Frage die Stadtbaurätin sagt das liegt
am teuren Boden auf dem die münchner
immobilien stehen selbst wenn jemand
jetzt nicht spekuliert sondern über ein
Grundstück verfügt ist es einfach nach
20 Jahren zckfache Wert und diese enorme
Wertsteigerung können wir kaum mit
Fördermitteln oder münchenmodell und
anderen Instrumenten reduzieren bislang
Zahlen EigentümerInnen Grundsteuer für
Ihr Grundstück je mehr Wohnfläche desto
höher die Steuer leere oder wenig
bebaute Flächen bleiben dadurch
günstiger sehr viel wirksamer wäre es
eben eine bodenwertsteuer einzuführen
also die Zunahme dieses bodenpreises
über die Steuer abzufangen und das
bedeutet dass jeder der Eigentum hat
Quadratmeter bodeneigentum und mehr
Steuern zahlt weil der Preis dann jedes
Jahr über den Verkehrswert zunimmt dass
er sich sagt ah wenn der so zunimmt muss
ich vielleicht effizienter damit
umgehen heißt wenn mehr Wohnungen auf
dem Grundstück stehen haben die
Eigentümerinnen auch mehr Einnahmen um
die neue Steuer zu begleichen die Ampel
will die Steuer aber nicht einführen
laut dem Bundesbauministerium sein viele
Kredite mit Grundstücken verbunden und
die Steuer zu aufwendig aber wo soll
dann der Wohnraum her über die
Nachverdichtung von Gewerbeimmobilien
Glauben Fachleute sprich Wohnungen über
Büros und
Supermärkten aber die Preise wachsen
schon längst über die Stadtgrenze hinaus
und dort liegt auch ein Teil der Lösung
wir haben nämlich einfach eine
ganz ganz konzentrierte man nennt das
monozentrische Verkehrserschließung alle
Verkehrswege insbesondere auch des ÖPNV
gehen auf diese Kernstadt München zu und
wir haben keine ringerschließung keine
ringbahnen die eigentlich so ein
bisschen die Preisanstiege in den
Wohnkosten den Bodenpreisen dämpfen
könnten weil man dann zwar weiter
draußen wohnen kann aber doch sehr
schnell erreichbar in den wichtigen
arbeitsplatzgebieten und Einkaufen
Kultur und so weiter sein könnte nur was
wenn die Leute in ihrem Viertel bleiben
wollen Pilar führt uns in die Wohnung
ihrer Eltern dort wo sie in ihrem alten
Zimmer lebt und arbeitet auf
quadratmet suchst du jetzt gerade aktiv
noch nach nach Sachen hier in Gegend
gerade oder es ist mal aktiver mal ist
es weniger aktiv das kommt auch so ein
bisschen drauf an wie frustriert man
gerade ist weil es ist natürlich auch
nicht immer wieder schön immer wieder
neu auf die Suche gehen zu müssen und
dann auch immer wieder diese Ablehnungen
zu erfahren und das macht schon auch
viel mit einem man weiß ja auch einfach
Z sie hat sich heute beim Dreh spontan
entschieden uns das alles von ihr zu
zeigen arbeitsatz erzählt man das dass
man mit 35 wieder zu Hause bei den
Eltern eingezogen ist und gerade bin ich
soweit zu sage soweit dass ich sage so
ja natürlich erzähle ich das denn es
soll ja auch einfach zeigen wie prekär
aktuell die in einer Gesellschaft sein
kann wie schwierig es ist obwohl man
eigentlich arbeitet und Geld verdient
trotz allem nicht in dem Viertel in dem
man gerne leben möchte eine Wohnung
findet und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
ich zeige euch das und das hat auch ein
wenig Überwindung gekostet aber es ist
so günstig werden Städte wie München
wahrscheinlich nie sein aber vielleicht
ja wenigstens bezahlbar für diejenigen
die ihr ganzes Leben dort verbracht
haben